mes chers compatriotes je suis ici dans
cette salle où je me suis marié je suis
ici à evry dans ma ville celle de ma
famille de mes enfants ma ville de coeur
une ville intense attachante jeunes
populaires cette ville où on se parle
toujours directement avec franchise
cette ville qui est une école une école
de la vie
j'ai appris tellement de mes concitoyens
alors oui je suis candidat à la
présidence de la république
[Applaudissements]
j'ai cette force en moi cette volonté de
servir mon pays c'est au delà des mots
c'est une conviction totale
je veux tout donner tout donner pour la
france qui m'a tant donné ministre
premier ministre
j'ai fait mon devoir vous me connaissez
sans jamais me ménager avec énergie en
parfaite loyauté avec le souci constant
d'être à la hauteur de la mission que
m'a confiée le chef de l'état à françois
hollande je veux dire mon émotion mon
affection
sa décision est celle d'un homme d'état
qui place l'intérêt général au-dessus de
tout elle nous oblige tous
je veux lui dire la chaleur de mes
sentiments ils se sont forgés à jamais
dans le prix douloureux que notre pays a
payé dans son engagement pour la liberté
je veux lui dire ma très grande fierté
d'avoir assumé
à ses côtés ses responsabilités immenses
intense et d'avoir engagé des réformes
essentielles pour la france pour
protéger les français
pour la compétitivité de nos entreprises
pour une autre école pour préserver
notre modèle social au coeur des
difficultés à ses côtés je n'ai jamais
cédé à la tentation de l'individualisme
de quitter le collectif non le service
de la france est bien plus grand que
soit le temps
oui le temps est venu d'aller plus loin
dans mon engagement
le sens de l'état
me fait considérer que je ne peux plus
être premier ministre tout en étant
candidat en accord total avec le
président de la république je quitterai
mes fonctions dès demain car je veux en
pleine liberté proposer aux français un
chemin
pourquoi ma candidature pourquoi donner
cinq ans de plus à la gauche
ces interrogations sont légitimes
je suis lucide je suis candidat parce
que la france doit peser de tout son
poids dans un monde qui n'a plus rien à
voir avec ce qu'il était menace
terroriste réchauffement climatique
effets néfastes de la mondialisation
affaiblissement de l'europe poussée de
l'extrême droite
je veux une france indépendante
indépendante inflexible sur ses valeurs
face à la chine de chine ping à la
russie de vladimir poutine à l'amérique
de donald trump à la turquie de recep
erdogan
il faut il faut dans ce monde une
expérience forte elle ne s'invente pas
elle ne s'improvise pas j'ai cette
expérience et je veux la mettre à profit
je m'engage parce que je ne veux pas que
la france
revivre ce traumatisme celui de 2002
d'une extrême droite au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
elle est aujourd'hui aux portes du
pouvoir son programme ruinerait les
petites gens les retraités les ouvriers
elle nous ferait sortir de l'europe et
de l'histoire à nous à nous tous de la
renvoyer dans les cordes
je veux me battre dans cette campagne
contre la droite
son candidat son programme avec ses
vieilles recettes des années 80
elle nous présente comme une avancée ce
qui est un recul social généralisé
je ne veux pas que les fonctionnaires
travaillent plus pour gagner moins
je ne veux pas que les déremboursements
massif de médicaments empêche les plus
modestes de se soigner
je ne veux pas que nos enfants aient
moins de professeurs que nos villes et
nos campagnes et moins de policiers ou
de gendarmes
je ne veux pas que l'on casse notre
sécurité sociale
l'hôpital public que nos aînés et moins
de protection et que les salariés
attendent 70 ans
soixante dix ans pour toucher une
retraite à taux plein ma candidature
c'est aussi une révolte
je suis révolté au fond de moi même à
l'idée que la gauche soit disqualifié de
cette présidentielle
et cette révolte je veux la faire nôtre
je constate la division à gauche mais
jusqu'à quand allons nous subir ce
spectacle voilà un beau motif de sursaut
il y à une exigence de rassemblement et
au fond de nous
je sais qu'il y a une envie de se
retrouver
moi même dans ma volonté de faire
évoluer ma famille politique j'ai pu
avoir des mots durs susciter des débats
des incompréhensions
ce sera la gauche c'est le débat c'est
la controverse mais j'ai toujours assumé
les décisions collectives parce que
c'est ça aussi l'esprit de la gauche
c'est mon histoire
bien sûr les uns et les autres nous
sommes différents mais nous sommes
ensemble la division est toujours une
affaire qui se fabrique à plusieurs
l'unité l'unité
aussi chacun devra faire un effort moi
moi le premier il faut être digne
se dépasser ma candidature est celle de
la conciliation
elle est celle de la réconciliation
je pose donc ce premier acte pour
l'unité parce qu'aujourd'hui j'ai une
responsabilité rassembler oui rassembler
car enfin quand on a gouverné avec
françois mitterrand
lionel jospin françois hollande on
partage quelque chose de grand deux
forts un même combat pour le progrès et
la justice sociale c'est une histoire un
fil commun je veux faire gagner tout ce
qui nous rassemble et la primaire qui
s'ouvre est un formidable moyen pour
recréer l'unité ce n'est pas que la
sphère des partis c'est votre
responsabilité
j'invite les femmes les hommes de gauche
les progressistes mais j'avais aussi
tous les français qui refusent l'extrême
droite qui refuse la régression sociale
que propose françois fillon à s'emparer
de ce moment à venir nombreux oui
nombreux
mobilisez-vous pour choisir librement
débattre et je le ferai moi-même avec
respect sens de l' écoute sans
polémiquer
sans jamais dénigré la gauche la gauche
est grande et belle quand elle parle à
tous les français et qu'elle rassemble
quand son destin se confond avec celui
de la france la france oui la france a
besoin de la gauche
garante de cet esprit français auquel je
veux nous devons rendre toute sa force
la laïcité qui est notre bouclier pour
assurer la tolérance pour protéger pour
que dans ce pays on puisse croire ou ne
pas croire se respecter l'égalité que
l'école doit promouvoir
l'égalité aussi c'est un combat
fondamental entre les femmes et les
hommes la fraternité qui fait que la
france est une nation où chacun est
préoccupée par le sort de son prochain
ce fameux modèle social français qu'il
faut moderniser mais aussi préserver
c'est de ne jamais fermer les yeux sur
la pauvreté les oublier les mal logés
les précaires les humilier de la vie
pour leur tendre la main
leur redonner la dignité à laquelle ils
ont droit
l'esprit français c'est la liberté celle
qui consiste à exercer quoi qu'il en
coûte
son esprit critique celui de voltaire
car l'esprit français
nous le savons est un docile rebelles et
en 2015
nous l'avons payé par le sens l'esprit
français
ses pensées en grand pour le monde comme
nous l'avons fait avec le président de
la république lors de la cop 21 ou en
l'engageant nos armées au mali au levant
l'esprit français
c'est la culture la création notre
magnifique exception notre patrimoine
nos paysages
notre créativité la french tech reconnu
sur tous les continents mais aussi notre
langue le français que des dizaines de
millions d'hommes et de femmes parlent
dans le monde
le français celui de rabelais d'hugo de
camus de césaire de beauvoir de patrick
modiano ou de leila slimani cet esprit
français je veux l'incarner le faire
respecter
l'entretenir le porter c'est pour moi
une mission fondamentale mais je veux
vous dire la vérité car je n'ai jamais
mâcher mes mots j'ai toujours nommés les
problèmes pour mieux les combattre les
communautarismes la ségrégation sociale
leur assise
l'antisémitisme les actes anti-musulmans
les actes antichrétiens les
discriminations qui nous fracture j'en
ai assez de ces discours qui nous
divisent qui stigmatise la nos
compatriotes musulmans là les réfugiés
fuyant la guerre et pourtant chaque fois
que je vais dans une commune une école
une entreprise une association je
ressens la même émotion partout des
citoyens se mobilisent pour nos aînés
pour les personnes qui vivent avec un
handicap pour ceux qui souffrent pour
ceux qui ont faim
notre pays aspire profondément à ce
récit commun il y a des ressources dans
la société française dans nos familles
il y à un optimisme
une générosité il faut aller chercher ce
qu'il ya de meilleur dans chacun de nous
les français ont besoin de retrouver un
esprit celui d'une société moins dure
plus solidaire plus fraternelle plus
moral nous partageons tous une belle
idée de la france
nous devons faire vivre cette idée je
veux mettre la france à la hauteur dames
nouveau la mondialisation doit être mise
au service des peuples
en clair je veux que les classes
populaires les travailleurs retrouvent
leur dignité leur capacité à faire a
créé à produire bref à construire ce
pays comme ils l'ont toujours fait ne
pas subir la mondialisation c'est
forcément pour moi qui suis profondément
européen par mes origines par mes
convictions par mon engagement
socialiste s'est refondée le projet
européen qui ne défend pas assez
aujourd'hui nos intérêts qui n'est pas
assez proches des peuples
je veux une europe forte dans le monde
qui investit dans l'avenir la jeunesse
le social m la france à la hauteur d'un
monde nouveau
ces mises et plus encore sur notre génie
créatif sur notre compétitivité sur
notre agriculture sur notre industrie
nos pme nos entrepreneurs nos
commerçants nos artisans nous salariés
parce que le travail est une valeur et
cela passe par l'investissement massif
dans des secteurs nouveaux qui feront la
croissance et les emplois de demain
économie verte transition écologique
énergies renouvelables numérique et les
sciences du vivant dans ce monde nouveau
la france sera plus forte elle sera une
grande nation car elle sera une nation
éducative
c'est à dire une nation qui mettent tout
sur nrj sono das plus d'audace encore
pour lutter contre les inégalités dans
l'éducation la formation tout au long de
la vie l'apprentissage la recherche la
santé une nation intelligente qui créent
de la valeur de la richesse de
l'épanouissement
ce sont les conditions indispensables
incontournable pour créer de l'emploi et
faire reculer le chômage
c'est ma priorité dans ce nouveau monde
nouveau et inquiétant l'état l'état a
toujours un rôle à jouer il ne peut pas
être mise en cause il ne peut pas être
démantelé il doit être l'expression
politique de la nation
un état qui protège contre l'insécurité
la délinquance la menace terroriste
un état qui protège les plus vulnérables
un état décentralisé présent avec ses
services publics forts aussi bien dans
les territoires urbains que ruraux qui
peuvent se sentir déplacés et je défends
vous le savez la ruralité mais aussi
présent dans les outre mer un état bien
géré
moderniser plus efficace car je veux
poursuivre la baisse durable de l'impôt
pour les classes moyennes et populaires
je veux aussi face à la crise
démocratique que la république notre
république fasse davantage confiance aux
français
on ne gouverne pas au xxème siècle comme
au siècle dernier
à l'heure où certains ne veulent
gouverner que par ordonnance
il faut toujours mieux impliquer les
citoyens les associations les élus les
partenaires sociaux car je crois à la
démocratie sociale dans les décisions
qui les concernent
nous devons inventer je proposerai un
nouvel équilibre pour nos institutions
entre l'exécutif le parlement les
collectivités territoriales qui doivent
assumer plus de responsabilités et les
citoyens qui doivent être mieux associer
davantage consultés et enfin ici à evry
je sais la force de notre jeunesse je
veux que la jeunesse toute la jeunesse
de mon pays réussissent et parce que je
suis un élu de ces quartiers populaires
je sais parfaitement que nous n'avons
pas encore répondu à ses attentes
la réussite de la jeunesse peut pas être
que financières l'épanouissement naît de
la capacité à concrétiser pour chacun
des projets à se réaliser dans le
travail la création d'entreprises dans
la culture la vie associative au service
des autres au service de la république
c'est cela l'engagement la réussite ne
se mesure pas au montant du compte en
banque
elle se mesure à la lumière que l'on a
dans les yeux et je veux que l'on
retrouve
je veux que mes compatriotes retrouvent
tous tous cette lumière dans les yeux
mes chers compatriotes de métropole des
outre mer de l'étranger nous sommes dans
un moment historique grave mais
passionnant qui est le fruit d'un
paradoxe alors même que l'espoir semble
s'éloigner que tout semble déjà écrit et
joué d avance
le peuple français ce grand peuple n'ait
jamais eu autant envie de reprendre les
rênes de son destin on nous dit que la
gauche n'a aucune chance
mais rien n'est écrit on nous dit
qu'elle ne rassemblera jamais quelle en
est incapable
rien n'est écrit on nous dit que
l'extrême droite est qualifié d'office
pour le second tour rien n'est écrit
on nous dit que françois fillon ait déjà
le prochain président de la république
rien et écrit nos vies valent mieux que
les pronostics
notre vie c'est nous tous nous tous qui
l'écrivons la gauche le coeur de la
gauche c'est refuser les déterminismes
les carcans et tous les schémas
préétablis
je veux je veux que nous conduisions la
gauche vers la victoire
donnez moi cette force mobilisez vous
venez nombreux au mois de janvier pour
choisir le destin du pays
je veux faire gagner tout tout ce qui
nous rassemble
vive la république et vive la france
foot
[Applaudissements]